so we go to artie's because they
contacted me on instagram they're like
we're back and we're doing fish and i'm
like man let's just get on a plane and
come here which i did and there's no
quarantine there's no nothing i mean
everybody's like there's there's i guess
is this this thing that the media is
doing to scare people that which i get
because i guess they don't want people
to travel but like
they're putting all this information out
there's like there's checkpoints at the
bridges and tunnels and the military's
in the airports it's like
there's none of that okay yeah i don't
even know but i mean there's none of it
but what would they do anyway tell you
to go home
like tell you to go go quarantine
okay that's a great point
sean what the hell are you doing i i
don't know i'm getting pizza
you go on home just a big military guy
you don't get sick boy you stupid [ __ ]
sir yes sir i will go home spider-man's
gone to the air yeah
i'm not powerless the empire endures
just screaming it's like who is this who
did you hire
um so we're sitting in artie's today
alfonse
d'amato walks in 82 year old
senator from the town i grew up in
island park he's from island park he's
from island park he's from brooklyn he
lived in island park
the motto's like read can you on mike
read a little bit about the motto set
this up for people because it is
truly amazing okay so d'amato was of
italian ancestry it was born in brooklyn
and raised on long island in the small
village of island park
which is great um he was the last
republican senator for new york from
1981
to 1999. the only charity he is a part
of
is the poker players alliance which is
it's a non-profit organization set up to
help protect and fight for the rights of
poker players in the united states
it's a lobby for the online poker yeah
yeah the charity
oh please tell us the book tell us to
ben can you tell us the title
find the title of his book and then tell
us the title tomorrow's book and then
we'll talk about the motto
because the lunch was amazing but you
gotta this is
if you if you didn't learn enough about
him by church and
shout out to him i might see him again
at this restaurant i'm not trying to
make things weird
but the name of the book he wrote is
absolutely perfect
the name of the book is power pasta and
politics
the word according to the world
according to senator aldamado look at
this
look at that right he looks like he's
like
he's an old-timer so listen to this he
hates trump
he goes like this right he sits down
he's talking to the owner of the
restaurant he goes
listen he goes you know why he lost this
election he goes you've got giuliani in
there giuliani's going over ukraine
hiring a bunch of crooks he goes
giuliani's a snake he goes i made
giuliani i put giuliani on he goes
giuliani's got no loyalty to anybody but
himself by himself and he goes that
guy's a scumbag and he goes
trump's souls are scumbagging because
you don't think trump's cheated on
everything
d'amato goes trump doesn't pay any of
his [ __ ] workers and the guy that
owns a restaurant goes
yeah he owed my buddy 80 grand he only
gave him 60. the mother was like you're
lucky he got 60.
you used to have to sue him to get money
and then it was so funny because i'm
sitting there with ben and we're
listening to this whole thing and i'm
like
ben don't you get it now or i don't get
invested in any of this [ __ ] emotionally
because this is just they're all
criminals like the motto is a criminal
the motto motto's a criminal like
giuliani who prosecuted the mob is like
hiring
mobsters to like help trump like they're
all full of [ __ ]
the whole thing's a grift and like it's
just so funny listening to motto talk
because anyone from new york who knew
trump knew he wasn't
like to say that donald trump cares
about the working man is like saying tim
dillon cares about the american vehicle
yeah it's hilarious my uncle's telling
me that like over thanksgiving dinner
when i was 10 about trump yeah before he
was even like a guy
yeah it was a known thing forever he has
no empathy the guy doesn't care at all
but it was so funny how just just uh the
motto unloading on giuliani for the
majority of the lunch i mean
look what did giuliani even do on 911
that's what i'm confused about how did
he become america's mayor
i think he was he digging people out of
the ground zero
he stood there and i think he was the
mayor
i mean i mean he was it was me performed
his mayoral duties and he was
you know i think he maybe gave a few i
don't remember any giuliani speech i
remember the famous bush thing
yeah where he got on the microphone and
he was like we're gonna find the people
who did this
i'm just saying this guy's gotta he look
he fell far from grace but he was built
up so hard
after 9 11. well he did a good job with
new york i think just from the beginning
yeah and
and there was a lot of reasons new york
cleaned itself up you know the infusion
of
foreign you know not foreign but capital
disney world all that [ __ ] you know made
change new york as a city but like the
economy got better the economy and 90s
just got better anyway
people remember sure um but giuliani
certainly should get some credit for
that because he did do a lot
of of good things for the city of new
york at the time but then he just has
become
a a goon and then you see
that this is who he was the whole time
it's just a goon
remember when he ran for president it
was like it was absurd at that point
that when you realized
he wasn't like as freezing about it but
he was just
inept that was when he first started
taking the armor when he's just oh he's
not good at this like he's just
he kept bringing up 911 everything every
question was 911. he's like well i was
from a
side ran a city there was attack i
allowed al-qaeda to
destroy the soul fights he's like listen
to me
bernard carrick and the saudi government
wired those buildings
and i sat there and i didn't say a
goddamn thing
do you have any idea what that's like
going to bed every night with the deaths
of 3 000 plus people on your hands
he got like [ __ ] because like you know
apparently firefighters hate him
because uh there was something where
they wanted to like
so at one point and there was day two or
three f911
like they realized there's a river of
molten gold under like tower seven or
some [ __ ]
under the rubble what a goddamn hellhole
in this country it's we keep going and
so giuliani goes we have to like you
know secure this i guess we can't have
the gold will swim away
so he pulls people off of like looking
for like firefighters bodies and victims
they go you have to go i don't know
collected molten gold with like
pale i don't know what he did
but they said he's reverend from lord of
the rings
he's like listen you must find the river
of gold
it's like my brother is in that building
he's gone
nothing to be done but there's a river
of gold
coursing through the veins of this city
and you gotta find it
what a sick sadistic society this is
that's america's mayor that's what he
did right you're like what did giuliani
do he directed the effort
of the fire department to find the river
of gold
that's what he did that should be a
children's book rudy
911 in the river of gold it's like a
weird harry potter book
rudy giuliani in the river of gold
what a [ __ ] creepy [ __ ]
dude i mean that is hilarious
yeah he just never he just but
but d'amato was unloading on him on lun
uh at lunch today
yeah he's like and then he got mad at
jimmy hayes who was the steakhouse
across the street he's like
that [ __ ] d'amato goes i go in
there with a gift card it's not working
jimmy's like giving me [ __ ] he's like
that cocksucker's sitting there drunk
he's sitting there drunk and jimmy does
like get drunk and just sit at the bar
and yell and [ __ ] and like
he said jamada's like i've been going
there 40 [ __ ] years this [ __ ]
[ __ ]
whatever we'll go back to this
restaurant tomorrow and eat and it's so
good everyone go there southwest virgin
island park
and then listen if nobody if i can't
ever go again i i at least i had this
where did you guys happen
oh we went all out we got tuna tartare
and buffalo calamari and the tuna
tidbits and swordfish and seoul and i
mean we just
it was really good i mean we're staying
in a dump what was the mother eating
swordfish oh seems kind of lame
yeah it was good i'm sure it's good just
seems like uh he's trying to you know
guys 82 he had colvin two weeks ago
what's up all these people yeah it's
just you're all just getting covered
eating fish
i don't know i don't know what they're
doing they don't give a [ __ ] my friend
michael has covered i'm like he's doing
it
does anyone die from this anymore i
don't think so
i gotta be honest i don't think i i
don't think so there's always a freak
cake there's always like a thing that
happens like my aunt donna collects
tragedies right so she'll be like she's
always at the ready with like some like
well one guy turned blue
like i don't wanna be insensitive but i
mean do you think this year
is a kind of a gimme for people whose
kids died of an overdose
what do you mean like we'll just tell
people who's coping
freak case oh yeah but that's got to be
horrible if they don't believe you like
like i'm like yeah you know um
john lost his fight with covin you go
covert
he's 24 years old it can it can affect
young people it can affect young people
you know it was shocking for us
and uh it was very you're like where did
he die
jail died in jail of govitta
nobody's like it's like somebody being
like honey honey
died of color 25. yeah don't you watch
the news it can happen
it can happen you know it's just he
started to have all these weird symptoms
and lesions on his forearms and wrists
and uh you know he started stealing all
of our
money is that parkour yes it's one of
these new symptoms they have where the
kids start stealing your money
and accusing you of molesting them
always sweating
cold you were sweating you're saying i i
know what you did to me you touched me
you let people touch me like it was
weird comfort
all of these odd symptoms of but it's
just so funny when you're listening to
d'amato
and then uh you're listening to trash
all these people just talking like
really kind of that
accurately about his perceptions about
things whether they're right or wrong
and
he was also trashing biden he's like
they got bites on tape
telling the council of foreign relations
that he's in the ukraine
his son's getting a lot of money because
you know cfr it's like real prestigious
you get in there you got to spend all
this money
he's doing all the but i mean he gets it
man he's wrong he's not wrong about
anything he got it and i was ben was
hearing and i'm like
that's politics in america you want to
know what it is
you might not like it you might want it
to be something else
maybe one day it will be i'm not telling
anyone not to organize
go force your floor vote for medicare
for all do whatever you want to do
but at the moment as it stands politics
in america it's a goon squad do you
think the cfr didn't back in the day
didn't [ __ ] with him
didn't didn't like reach out to al aldo
i don't know i think he was probably a
guy that they [ __ ] lied he's a
criminal
yeah these are all criminals i mean like
these people
politics is a is crime it's like it's
legalized bribery and corruption it's
what it is
i mean political parties used to
literally be they they ran gangs and
they rang yeah
yeah so i mean it's just like this is
who these people are the direct
descendants of in
in every meaningful way and you know you
can hear that when they're at lunch and
just the way he's 82 it's so funny
because this [ __ ] i go in there
with a gift card
and you know like jimmy's being like
this [ __ ] tried to rob me
you know like on the other side it's
just
like yeah no al this has already been
used yeah no it hasn't keep running it
keep running he's just trying to get a
scandal i was trying to get a scam
trying to get a few free stakes that's
really all that come politics in america
comes down to a few free steaks
can you get a few pieces of meat on the
arm i mean can you imagine how much
how much better it tastes than when you
[ __ ] like put your wallet out like
just getting
getting like someone like a grip yeah it
just tastes i want to go back just for a
minute tonight 11 the funny and i've
told this anecdote on the show before
but the funniest thing i ever saw in
like three years of
doing uh leading tours in new york city
like on and off for three years on a
double-decker bus
there was this guy named frank he was
like this kind of intense guy but not
like a conspiracy guy right
never like you know we smoke bots and
[ __ ] good dude
never really like did tours never really
got complaints
he just got really he just like
got really [ __ ] like heated one day
when and i never i was taking his bus
because i was just sitting on the bus to
deadhead
to where i was taking the subway back to
my house he was just doing like this you
know downtown route and i lived in
brooklyn at the time
and i was sitting there and he goes
somebody on the bus goes
uh you know the fire you know man the
fire department they were all heroes you
know running in those buildings and he
goes
franco's that's what you think he goes i
was there
he goes those firemen were cowards they
were running out of those buildings
he goes they didn't save anybody they
were running out of those buildings
he goes to cops to farm and they were
cowards they were crying they were
running away
and the faces of the people were so
disturbed by how matter-of-fact he was
he was like i saw it
because he was not characteristic for
him to flip out like this yeah he
literally
saw it or believed he saw it like he was
like i saw it the cowards they ran out
of those buildings
they didn't go anywhere near they could
have been running out as they were
collapsing yeah
he gonna say he goes they didn't go
anywhere near those but i just never
seen someone just flip so quickly it was
just [ __ ] phenomenal